[Musique]
a cessé de produire en
Novembre de l'année dernière à cette époque
nous faisons un processus de deux
mise en service, c'est-à-dire placer le
centre de sécurité, puis aller de l'avant si
il y a pour d'autres processus de déforestation
[Musique]
le projet que nous présentons
demande en termes de capacité
remplacer plus ou moins ce que j'avais
perdu au point de connexion donc
nous avons laissé derrière nous un projet de 628
charbon que nous introduisons ici env.
650 mégawatts d'énergies renouvelables plus un cran
de 365 mille wattleico 264 de
l'énergie éolienne à laquelle nous associerons
une importante capacité de stockage
avec piles
[Musique]